بغض النظر عن الاسلام الحركي لكن الاسلام
ايدولوجيا
الاسلاميون عبر تاريخهم بمعنى يعني حضور
الاسلام السياسي منذ اربعه قرون والذي جاء
بعد حرب افغانستان والثوره الاسلاميه في
ايران ثم التطورات لاحقا بعد حرب الخليج
وبعد السلام العربي الاسرائيلي كل ذلك همم
ادى الى تمكين
الاسلاميين من النفاذ الى شعوب
الشعوب الاسلاميه بمختلف في تكويناتها
باعتبارهم يطرحوا همم بديلا لهذا القادم
من الغرب الاستعماري
وبديلا لحلول الوطنيه همم لم تاخذ
بالاسلام كالاحزاب الاشتراكيه والاحزاب
القوميه بالوطن العربي على سبيل المثال
وبعض الدول الاسلاميه
اعتقد اليوم الفكره الاسلاميه لا زالت
ايميل في ظل همم صراعات كبرى ربما يقدم
همم
الاسلام السياسي نفسه راس الحربه فيها اا
بالرد على سبيل المثال على طروحات مثل
الطروحات صومائيلهن انتم بخصوص صدام
الحضارات نحن واا هؤلاء الاسلاميون يقدمون
اليوم الدليل تلو الاخر همم على مفهوم
الهويه مفهوم الامه مفهوم الزراعه الثقافي
وانهم هم الذين يقودونه ضد الغرب الغرب
اعتقد يعزز هذه المقولات اهي عبروا عدم
العداله والكيل بمكيالين في كثير همم من
القضايا لكن هذه الامور ليست بالمطلق لان
هناك اسباب كامله لدى الاسلاميين همم
الاسلام السياسي اقصد هذا الاسلام السياسي
تمتع منذ الثمانينات
وحتى همم فتره قريبه الى عهد ما يسمى
بالربيع العربي بدعم بكثير من الانظمه
والحكومات العربيه التي كانت تغطي هذا
الاسلام خاصه بمرحله الصراع مع الكتله
الشيوعي الشرقي ونحن على سبيل المثال وليس
الحصر نعلم ان من بين من بين اسباب ظهور
وتقويه الجهاد الاسلامي في افغانستان هو
الاحتلال السوفياتي بين قوسين الشيوع
الكافر لدوله اسلاميه هي افغانستان وكيف
تعزز همم هذا الجهاز همم اذا البعد الدولي
والغطاءات الدوليه كانت مهمه جدا هذا
الاسلام يخدم الاسلام السياسي يخدم
متطلبات في اطار صراعات دوليه واقليميه
نعم نعم
استاذ عمر العقود
على الماضيه تمكن الاسلاميون على المستوى
الذاتي من اختراق الكثير من مؤسسات الدول
في ظل هذه العلاقه التحالفيه
وانشا الكثير من مصادر التمويل